welcome to biology professor today we
are talking about bacterial growth
particularly how bacteria grows in a
liquid nutrient culture there are four
phases lag phase log phase also known as
exponential growth phase stationary
phase and death phase or logarithmic
decline phase let's talk about these
four phases the first one lag phase if
we look at over here it's during the
early part of growth when you have
inoculated the culture there's no active
cell division because the bacteria are
preparing to divide so they are
replicating their DNA they are making
necessary enzymes to move into log phase
which will draw here long phase is when
there is rapid exponential cell division
the bacteria are dividing very quickly
but they are using up nutrients and they
are secreting waste products this is
what eventually leads to stationary
phase stationary phase is when enough of
the nutrients are gone and enough of the
waste products have built up that
basically the rate of cell growth is
approximately equal to the rate of cell
death that's why we aren't seeing in
that increase in amount of bacteria once
we get to stationary phase and at this
point the nutrients are still being used
up the waste products are salt are still
building up and this is what brings us
to death phase or logarithmic decline
this is when the rate of cell death
exceeds the rate of cell division so
that you have an overall decrease in the
amount of bacteria in the culture and
these are the phases of bacterial growth
so we just talked about the four phases
of bacterial growth now I want to talk a
little bit more about what happens in
Phase two the logarithmic things that's
where the bacteria are exponentially
dividing it's very rapid and it occurs
through a process called binary fission
so the way that binary fission works is
through these four steps in step number
one you have the bacterial cell
elongating getting longer also the DNA
inside it is being replicated so you get
two sets of DNA then the cell wall and
the cell membrane begin to pinch N and
divide in step two in step three the
cross wall forms this separates the
original DNA from the replicated DNA
that occurred in step one then you get
in step four the two daughter cells
fully separating into new cells this
process
we'll continue multiple times and the
time it takes to get from step one to
step four it's called the generation
time some bacteria can go through this
process very very quickly in fact e coli
is a generation time only about 20
minutes
which explains why it's able to divide
so quickly
and reach that logarithmic growth thanks